so via Senor fresh off Saturday Night
Live and she has some breaking news
block Aquaman himself
you slept with him no I wish wait did
you work with him on the show okay he's
only five foot two though yeah he's
actually way smaller Saturday you know I
shared on my Instagram I was like you
know what I need to dress up on stage
and show my booty because it's good okay
okay and um I said fans you deserve a
show I'll wear tighter pants so you can
see the booty and then Mama commented
he's like yeah yeah Mama we love to see
that booty
oh my God I mean what did you do she had
to change her pants
[Laughter]
a direct d
ude Dear Mama you're lying I'm not did
you reply to him felt like I was
aggressive and I sent my number and he
never texts